"This episode of DNews is brought to you by
the Toyota Corolla.
Let’s lead the way."
This week, NASA’s released an awesome, closeup
image of Ceres, the body the Dawn ===spacecraft
is on its way to visit.
But what exactly is Ceres?
Hey guys, Amy here on DNews.
If you aren’t sure what exactly Ceres is,
you’re definitely not alone.
Ceres is a dwarf planet that scientists also
refer to as an embryonic planet.
When the planets in our solar system formed
from the swirling cloud of gas and dust, Ceres
wanted to be a planet, too, but Jupiter had
other ideas.
The gas giant is so massive that its gravitational
pull was enough to stop Ceres from accumulating
enough material to be a fully formed planet
in its own right.
Instead, it joined all the other leftover
debris that makes up the asteroid belt.
But Ceres wasn’t always considered an embryonic
planet, because it wasn’t always obviously
one of thousands of bodies in the asteroid
belt.
Ceres was discovered in 1801 by Sicilian astronomer
Father Giuseppe Piazzi.
This small body between Mars and Jupiter’s
orbits solved a major astronomical quandary:
why there was no planet in an orbit where
astronomers predicted there should be one?
Now there was one.
Piazzi named it Ceres after the Roman goddess
of corn and harvests, and it was entered into
textbooks, which were admittedly few in the
early 1800s.
-
But as more objects were found in the vicinity
of Ceres -- Vesta, Juno, and Pallas -- that
first body became less unique and special.
Taken together, these small bodies were collectively
called asteroids or minor planets, but they
were still considered planets.
They even had symbols like the major planets
do.
But as more and more small bodies were found,
the scene became a little too crowded.
In the 1850s, American astronomer, B.A. Gould
suggested doing away with the small bodies’
symbols and replacing them with a new standard
shorthand notation: a circle with a number
inside, the number correlating to the order
in which the bodies were discovered.
The system was really simple and was adopted
pretty quickly.
Ceres’ designation varied between publications
in the mid 1800s, called a little planet,
an asteroid, a planet, and sometimes multiple
names at once.
By the 1860s Ceres was folded into the group
of bodies that lies between Mars and Jupiter,
all of which were called asteroids.
Until 2006 when Ceres’ planet-like qualities
earned it a reclassification as a dwarf planet
along with Pluto.
But like Pluto, Ceres being a dwarf planet
doesn’t make it any less incredible.
It’s about 590 miles across, large enough
that it makes up for 25 percent of the mass
in the asteroid belt but is still 14 times
less massive than Pluto.
And there are signs that Ceres contains large
amounts of water ice beneath its surface and
water vapor perhaps rooted in sublimating
ice.
If Ceres turns out to be just 25 percent water,
it will have more fresh water than the Earth.
NASA’s Dawn spacecraft is going into orbit
around the dwarf planet on March 6 this year,
so we’ll have some answers soon!
Are you excited to see what we’re going
to learn about this little planet turned asteroid
turned dwarf planet?
Let us know in the comments below or you can
catch me on Twitter as @astVintageSpace.
And don’t forget to subscribe for more DNews
every day of the week.